please discuss how discipline in one
area doesn't make up for slack in other
areas for example the fitness guru who
has no savings mmm yeah you know this is
something that we all have to work out
watch out for is the fact that we we
focus on our strengths right that's what
we do that's what people do so you get a
person that's smart
a really intellectual person and they
let themselves go physically right you
know or you get a person that's a
physical stud but then they're not gonna
challenge their brainpower or like the
question that was you know the example
here that was posed you know someone
that's a fitness guru or a party guru
him I'm throwing that one out there cuz
some people were too good that sure or
they you know they're an entrepreneur
entrepreneur and so they're driving a
new Mercedes but it's leased and they're
behind on payments so strategic yeah
yeah that so you know I mean you take
another example is what about the
business person that doesn't have time
for their family right yeah and so
that's not good so I think the focus
here is do we try and we all have to be
try to be well-rounded and not focus so
much on one area that you're gonna let
some other area go that's target
fixation is what that is right is you
walk into a room and you get fixated on
one target in one bad guy you think
there's one bad guy so you focus all
your energy and then you're getting
flanked that's the target fixation you
can't let that happen you can't let it
happen on the battlefield you can't let
it happen on life so look out for that
when you do this um and I'll tell you
this is actually a reality of the
situation I'm I try and maintain this
balance but I've been actually working a
lot lately and what and this is a clear
indicator to me that I've overbooked
myself is last week we had to sky we had
to skip a day of jiu-jitsu to record
I mean we don't do that right when do we
record rerecord after jiu-jitsu but I
knew I had so much stuff going on that I
said hey we got a we got to record it
this time because I gotta get of this
other stuff done cuz I'm travelling in
this and that and so we had to skip the
jujitsu so that is it red flag to me mmm
that says I need to I need to tighten up
I need to get my you know get my
schedule back in check so that I can do
the things that I need to do of course
what do I say about the situation it's
fine you know what
can't train jiu-jitsu that day because
I'm trying I got some travel coming up
good I'm gonna heal up my shoulder a
little bit more I'm gonna do no I'm
gonna it's good fine
but it is an indicator of when things
start going in the wrong direction maybe
I'm getting targeted fixated on you know
too much work at a certain time which to
me again I will run this thing in the
red as you say I like I like running in
the red right I'm in the red and I got
no problem like we will go hard in the
numbers of hours I've been or I will
work will have actually known impact on
how much I'm gonna tell them to spend
with my family and do jiu-jitsu and all
that so I'll just do it all but there is
a capacity that you reach where you go
okay now one of these things that has
just started to slide now I need to make
sure that my levels get re re levels yes
you might say equalized is what I should
have said so back to the subject don't
be a one-trick pony
you know be a jack-of-all-trades and
then master a few of those trades so you
can emphasize fitness guru you can
emphasize intellectual power you can
emphasize jiu-jitsu but don't put a
hundred percent of your effort into one
area because eventually it will take you
you won't have anything else and by the
way if you put all your you know if you
put all your all your eggs in the basket
of intellectual power now you're
unhealthy and you die right that doesn't
you know I don't care how smart you are
you
can't do 2+2 when you're dead so don't
put all your focus a hundred percent
into one area
don't become unbalanced in your
disciplines spread it around and hold
the line good yeah I get it it kind of
feels like like you can be understood
that um I'm real good at I don't know
fitness and it's easy to justify
yourself you know like you're you're say
okay I'm real good at fitness you know
fitness guru and I go around and then I
see out I know I go to the store go to
some party and I see this other guy
who's like socially he's just a hundred
percent everyone likes me such a nice
charismatic guy makes a lot of money you
know and all this stuff but he's not in
that good of shape or I don't know he
smokes in whatever you know it's easy I
think a lot of people it feels like it's
easy to justify well that guy's in bad
shape so who cares I wouldn't want any
of that
I wouldn't want all the money you know
all this stuff it seems like and you
know if the other guys saying yeah you
might be in good shape guess what
yeah nice Toyota Corolla you're driving
he's all negative on it yeah yeah yeah
so both those guys should issued instead
of saying hey you know what they should
do walk up and be like hey man you know
what I notice you're pretty successful
financially I would like to get in the
game with you a little bit and and learn
from you about that any other guy should
say oh well you know what it looks like
you're in pretty good fitness levels I
would like to get in the game with that
let's work together and improve
ourselves and go out and kick ass and
dominate are you in I'm in let's do this
instead what does a normal person do
they do exactly what you said justify
criticize cut people down instead of
building them up yeah and once you have
to be careful of if I was to go to you
and say hey you know echo I got a lot of
money I can tell you don't have a lot
I'll help you out that's that can be
offensive to some people yeah did you
think thank you
I'm gonna need your help money think I'm
worried about money when I got abs like
geez you know so what we have to do is
instead of if you if I came to you and
said echo dude I want abs like you got
sir can you help me get in the game and
then we form a little relationship and
now I say to you man so what's your
what's your main income stream dude you
know what are you doing and you say well
you know I got these two clients you got
a website no not really
well why don't you have a website you
got any social media to advertise on you
know and we go though that road and we
build up we take care of each other so
we want to do as people yeah kind of
like you ever seen the guys who go they
see like a football player or something
I mean like I kick his ass though
you know you know that King guy you know
he's like some success and I kick his
ass though yeah yeah then well I've told
the story before in the SEAL Teams it's
oh no one no one is good if a guy like
we have guys in the SEAL Teams that are
literally you know world-class athletes
in whatever world-class triathlete
world-class sailor world-class whatever
and so oh you owe your your world cost
triathlete oh yeah that guy's really
good triathlete that's cool he's a
really bad shot someone is gonna chime
in and cut him down that's the way it
goes slack no slack slack